多花点时间精力在自己的事业上，
多花点时间精力在我怎么能多挣钱这件事情上，
多花点时间精力怎么能照顾好我的身体，
照顾好我的情绪，
怎么能够发现身边跟我同频的人，
怎么能够发现身边有趣的人，
哎，
怎么能够经营好一个正向的关系，
多花时间精力在这件事情上，
美好的人和事儿都会接踵而至。
我今年是29岁，
我老公小我两岁，
我们处谈恋爱到结婚到现在一共是五年了，
结婚四年，
我感觉他的情绪很不稳定，
给我带来了很大的困扰，
我觉得我很痛苦，
我想得到一些好的建议。
我是远嫁，
我现在这么痛苦，
可能也是因为我的恋个呢，
还没有完全治好他过去有一些比较严重的问题，
现在已经改了，
但是情绪不稳定这一块的话，
他就一直没有改掉，
他情绪不稳定的时候，
最严重的时候会有什么表现呢？
他莫名其妙的生气，
然后会砸钱呀，
砸东西呀，
莫名其妙的生气，
就你没惹他，
他自己会爆发出来就生气了是吧？
我在很平静的去说明问题，
去说我的委屈的时候，
他就会有很强烈的反应去给我反馈，
然后就发脾气，
最莫名其妙的就是我在网上买的那种益生菌嘛，
然后他就觉得是胶产品。
我就发很大的脾气，
会把我的东西丢到门外去，
把我的宠物丢到门外去，
你买的益生菌是花了他的钱还是花你自己的钱啊，
你花你自己的钱买益生菌，
他把你宠物这些东西都丢门口，
对你买那个益生菌很贵吗？
就忘记了，
反正不会太贵吧，
一两百块钱之类的，
反正就几百块钱，
那你想问我什么问题呢？
现在他没有这么严重了，
我现在是在一个一线城市上班，
我们现在也是异地，
他现在是在家里面创业做电商的，
他有父母帮衬，
然后我的收入大概是一年20来万，
他收入应该会比我高，
我没有管他的钱，
经济上面我们各管各的，
放假了嘛，
然后我就回去婆家了，
嗯，
然后我回去前三天，
他每天都会有一些小事情，
就是让我很不开心，
就比如我发现他的相册里面把我的照片删了，
之前我给她发照片是在微信里面发的，
我发现聊天记录里面也没有我的照片了，
通讯录里面之前也是有照片的，
这照片也没有了，
我就问他，
他就很那种，
就说我我也不知道怎么就删掉了啊，
那我做电商我也说这个手机跟那个手机登的，
可能聊天记录就丢失了，
但是我知道当时我发给他的时候，
我是当面发给他的，
我当面帮他保存的，
我知道是在哪个手机上，
是在4号的时候跟他发生一些口角，
然后他摔门就走。
了嘛，
我也觉得很生气，
我就直接买了高铁票，
我公公知道我走了，
还去高铁站找我，
但是我老公没有去找我，
也没有发信息给我，
就是要留我的那一种，
就直到现在他也没有联系过我，
我就感觉比较痛苦，
有没有一些好的经历让我过得好受一点？
坦率的说，
姑娘啊，
我觉得一个女人要过得好，
就一定要非常非常清晰的知道自己跟谁在一起是开心的，
跟谁在一起是向上的，
跟谁在一起变得越来越优秀的，
跟谁在一起是挣钱越来越多的，
跟谁在一起是身体越来越好的。
如果你跟一个人在一起，
你身体变得不好，
情绪变得不好，
也没有变得更优秀，
也没有更热爱生命的话，
那就是一段有毒的关系。
反正我这段有毒的关系，
甚至如果是我亲爹亲妈，
他带给我的是有毒的关系的话，
我都会逃得远远的，
我为我自己说的话负责任，
我也是知行合一的这样一个人，
我可以在法律上去赡养或者怎么怎么样，
但是任何一个人出现在我的生命里，
如果他出现在我的生命里，
只会让我情绪变差，
身体变差，
整个精神状态变差，
没有让我得到任何的成长，
没有任何正向的情感反馈的话，
我就是远离，
我就离得远远的，
我就是得找好的人际关系，
有好的气场。
我感觉啊，
我对我自己负责任这件事情是永远排在第一位的，
我永远在乎我自己的感受，
我不害怕别人骂我。
哎呀，
你是不是太自我了？
是不是太那个自私了？
是不是太利己了？
我承认你要问我的态度的话，
就是一个男人出现在我的生命里，
他只能让我情绪不好就拖我的后腿啊，
在经济上对我也没有任何的帮衬，
我又没有孩子，
打飞机跑啊，
必须说飞机我能养活我自己啊，
对不对？
你一年能挣20万对吧？
你自己也有自己的事业前景啊，
你多花点时间精力在自己的事业上，
多花点时间精力在我怎么能多挣钱这件事情上，
多花点时间精力怎么能照顾好我的身体，
照顾好我的情绪，
怎么能够发现身边跟我同频的人，
怎么能够发现身边有趣的人，
怎么能够经营好一个正向的关系，
多花时间精力在这件事情上，
美好的人和事儿都会接踵而至，
好好就这样啊，
嗯，
拜拜，
你自姐是怎么爱自己的啊？
爱自己有一个前提，
就是接纳我身上的优点，
我身上的缺点，
我身上的善，
我身上的恶，
我身上的自私，
我身上的虚荣，
我身上的一切，
我都接纳他。
我不害怕任何一个人评价我，
不害怕任何一个人骂我，
不害怕任何一个人去诋毁我。
我现在甚至就是爱自己到什么程度呢？
我觉得这个社会上可能有1000万我的分身，
有的人他看到那个分身是暴虐的，
是自私的，
是那种心眼儿多的，
那就是我。
我承认你所看到那个角色就是我，
你所厌弃的那个角色就是我，
我接纳。
自己的一切人，
其实当你开始完全接纳你自己了的时候，
好像就是周围的人，
慢慢也就开始学着怎么接纳你。
记得点赞关注哦。